all right earlier we talked about the
defense attorney in the trial over the
killing by police of ahmad arbury
now we are going to talk about the judge
in the kyle rittenhouse trial now i want
to i mean listen i would this this trial
has become so toxic where if you have
anything but a completely black and
white view on if you have a black and
white view on the matter
half of the audience flips out on you if
you have a gray area view of different
aspects of the trial then everybody ends
up upset for the most part i've already
said
i believe that the entire kyle
rittenhouse situation
is a result
of educational
parenting and cultural failure in the
united states some of the most
disgusting aspects of gun culture
militia culture
vigilantism etc in the united states and
at the same time i believe that the
facts in the case support a self-defense
a self-defense acquittal
at least
on two of the three main counts in the
case
given
the narrow nature with which those
statutes are written i've already said
it okay so please don't come back to me
on that stuff now i already went out
last week
i went over last week when the judge
bruce schroeder flipped out on the
prosecutor binger in the case
um saying
you were getting dangerously close to
violating the fifth amendment when you
started asking kyle rittenhouse during
testimony about his uh the timing of
when he is first giving his full version
of events you're sort of going after his
right to silence and implying guilt
there uh and the the judge kind of
flipped out on the prosecutor uh and
people have their view about that
now i've gotten a bunch of emails from
people saying david the judge is fine
there's no issue with the judge at all
first and foremost i would urge folks if
you've not been following the case over
the killing of a mod arbory compare the
role of the judge in the written house
case the role of the judge in that other
case judges in a way
are like referees in sports and if you
follow sports if you're talking about
the referee
it's a problem okay if the story in a
baseball games in a baseball game
becomes the umpire and their ball and
strike calls it's probably because the
umpire is at least
theoretically doing something wrong
because they're making themselves their
presence known in a basketball game if
the biggest topic of discussion is the
foul calls by referees the referees are
in they're doing too much and they're
playing too big a role it's probably not
good and much the same way
in the written house case
the judge has put himself front and
center to to even give you an example
the judge is so wacky and cartoonish
that people send me for my sound board
for when we broadcast the trial clips of
the judge first of all there's the judge
being obsessed with food and and so for
example by the way how are the calzones
the food is here yeah
let's take a break lunch is here
pizza is here
but uh we have subway tomorrow okay the
judge at one point asking the jury
not to go to the bathroom in the
courtroom like literally do not use the
courtroom as your bathroom whatever you
do make sure you go to the bathroom
somewhere other than the car
and then also the judge seemingly
completely technologically inept
and the defense being able to use in
their favor that the judge is completely
inept at one point referring to pixels
as pickles uncharged piccolos okay so
that's that
the judge also has a reputation for
attorneys wanting to avoid him
and in addition to that the
flipping out on the prosecutor
whether or not you believe the content
of the flipping out was justified
many
legal analysts have said
when the judge flips out on the
attorneys for one side that is known to
influence jurors and thus when the
jurors see the judge flipping out only
on one side
um you could make the case that that is
influencing the jury now you could say
well maybe the
the judge should be flipping out on one
side fine
you send the jury out in order to do it
and um so so that's that now a couple
other things that the judge has done
that are sort of questionable
during cross-examination of a reporter
from real america's voice who is pro
kyle rittenhouse posted pro kyle
writtenhouse things to social media
the
um uh prosecutor on cross-examination
started getting into what exactly is
real america's voice
and real america's voice is just a wacky
right-wing channel it's sort of like if
alex jones infowars
reporters are there it would be very
relevant for the jury to understand what
is infowars and when the prosecutor got
to the question about what is the
political leaning of real america's
voice the judge bails out the defense
and says you're not going to ask that
youtube channel yes
do you have your own independent website
that you operate uh i do have an
independent website yes what's that
called drewhlive.com
what is that that's my own independent
website but is it like a
a news source is it an independent
website
of what type for myself
you characterized yourself as a
professional commentator what does that
mean that means that i comment on the
news professionally on a daily basis
professionally meaning you're paid yep
who pays you i am employed by real
america's voice right
real america's voice yes what is that
that is a news commentary breaking news
uh website they have their own apps
and uh yeah website
other than getting paid by real
america's voice do you get paid by any
other source to do your professional
commentating no
is your drew h live website part of real
america's voice no
the things that you post on your
website drew h live do you also share
those with
real america's voice
um depending on
what's going on where i'm at um but this
is unrelated to what happened in kenosha
because i was not employed by real
america's voice at the time
that's something that's happened since
then yes
and uh does real america's voice have
any sort of
political
bias or agenda or anything like that
what is the development it goes to the
bias of the witness your honor
the
bias in what respect i i
anyway to cut to the end the um the
judge doesn't allow that to be asked
about and again it's like if the witness
were alex jones and you're not allowed
to inquire about what infowars is it's
absolutely wild
and then lastly a very strange comment
which some are saying is a political
comment
one day they were having asian food
asian food as the judge says
and the judge made what some are calling
a political comment by saying hopefully
the food's not stuck on one of those
boats in long beach harbor alluding to
this supply chain controversy and of
course they're in wisconsin folks so
it's completely unnecessary comment but
it's a joke that goes some argue to
political bias uh let's hope for one
o'clock i don't know the uh hope the
asian food isn't coming it's on isn't on
one of those boats in long long beach
harbor
[Laughter]
now even if he doesn't mean thanks to
biden it's on one of those boats
it's off color and it's not appropriate
and the judge is very very wacky so i
my feeling is
while on the major
charges
not guilty follows the facts
the entire thing seems like a foregone
conclusion and the judge seems to be
very much so helping that along so
that's the judge let's now go to the mom
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries is curiosity
stream and they're one of our sponsors i
know netflix hulu amazon they have some
good documentaries but curiosity stream
is where you find the best selection
hands down curiosity stream has the
newest most critically acclaimed titles
you can watch on any device i've been
using curiosity stream for about a year
now it is my go-to
i just finished watching autonomy about
the future of automation there are
documentaries on curiosity stream about
politics economics science technology
history travel curiosity stream is
perfect for learning about just about
any new topic also great for unwinding
mentally escaping like with a nature
documentary and curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off a subscription
which comes out to 15 bucks a year not a
month a year
go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below